okay perfect
um so hi everyone
um welcome to this uh this first uh
technical Talk of the day yeah
um today I wanted to talk about data
frames because it's probably something
all of you already use in your
day-to-day lives
just a bit of perspective about who I am
and why I did that so yes I am a retail
researcher I actually left Academia
right after my PhD defense
um now I work in a company called
dataiku that's a software vendor who
basically edits a platform for people
who click people who code
um FYI we are hiring
and well in our product we do have
something that is called the flow the
flow is basically a graph that allows
you to recursively build objects should
it be data sets models but in between
those buildable items you have well
tasks to execute and most often to
execute those tags you will rely on code
very simply put you have one or more
input data sets you're going to write
code to well read that data process it
and then write the results somewhere
else
that's a very simplified vision of data
processing of course but the point is
that between the data and the code there
needs to be an interface and this is
where the data frame comes in
so when I started as a data scientist
back in 2017 everybody was reading that
book python for data analysis that was
basically the user guide for the
well-known pandas Library
fast forward well to November 2022 we
are now at pandas version 1.5.2
which has gone a long way since Panda
0.1 which was released according to Pi
Pi on December the 25th of 2009.
and in between of course
well there have been many other
contenders to actually allow people to
use the data frame framework to
manipulate data
quick disclaimer the talk of today is
not going to be a benchmark for all of
those there already have been a few
actually uh talks in pi data about
comparing the performance between these
guys
what I wanted to do is a bit more
different in a way I wanted to look at a
technical view of a few of them and not
really compare how they do in terms of
well raw performance but instead try to
understand what they mean in terms of
user experience what they mean in terms
of like what's happening under the hood
both in terms of memory management and
let's say execution Frameworks
and of course given the fact that where
we are limited on time today I picked
four of them of course pandas as a base
reference
um and also so task data frame mode in
and polars you will understand why I
picked those additional three later on
but that will be our menu for the day
we're going to start with uh probably
the most important part which is the
apis and let's say more generally the
user experience how does it feel to
write code when you're using any of
those Frameworks
to understand that before diving into
the specifics it's important to take a
look at what a data frame is from a data
structure perspective
and it's actually something fairly let's
say singular when you look at it because
when you look at the data frame it's
basically something that is double
indexed so it has so any data item
inside the data frame has two labels a
label uh relative to the row and the
label relative to the column
it also has a type
and
let's say almost all of those Frameworks
when they are implemented they assume
that
the data structure looks something like
this
let's start with pandas and yes you're
going to see a bit of code today
fortunately this is not code that I'm
going to execute live so no demo effect
you will have to trust me on that
but if we start with uh pandas well
all in all it's quote unquote nothing
more than just well a dictionary of
series object
and where you have basically the column
names as labels in that dictionary as
dictionary Keys sorry
um
well accessing the data is where it
becomes interesting because probably
most of you know how to access data in
pandas but you may have your own
favorite way of doing it we can even try
to like make a show of hands if we we
are to access let's say one column
inside pandas who would go for option
number one by attribute
all right who would go for option number
two with Dot Lock
who would go with option number three
Dot ilock
all right so there is no best way of
doing it of course that's the point
depends on how you're going to write
your code of course but my point here is
that well
pandas offers you options
question is well what's the best way of
doing it is there a right way of doing
it
that's the thing when you start
implementing many ways of doing the same
thing especially within the same tool
then you have your users getting a bit
confused and even when you start looking
into doing something simple as a
beginner you're like okay but I see that
there are many other ways of doing it
I'm going to take some time to think it
through and to come with the most
generic and most efficient solution
I suppose everyone knows what happens
next you get stuck into this Rabbit Hole
of finding a global Optimum that may or
may not exist but you end up not doing
something even simple that's one of the
main pitfalls and if you take a look at
let's say the size of the pandas API you
will run this kernel comment in a
terminal
the result will be over 200. there are
more than 200 pandas dot something
something items that are documented
that's a lot
so when you have so many options of
course you are free to do things but
well with that freedom can come also a
bit of complexity
so
here I have listed a few not really
empty patterns but things that can be
done
potentially in a better way so I am
French as you can guess with my accent I
like to complain about stuff as you have
seen in the previous presentation so I
will mostly complain about not just
pandas but also the other libraries out
there but there are also a few good
things so
take things with a grain of salt
first of all well as a beginner when you
start using pandas you're like okay this
is really cool I can write this uh
fairly convoluted lines of code and you
start going what is called uh the
mutation pattern you're like I'm going
to Define one object I'm going to
perform operations and then I'm going to
Define another variable that will take
that object and do something else and so
on and so forth thing is under the hood
you're going to create a lot of objects
this is going to take a lot of memory
this is not going to fare well if you
are working on limited resources
instead people would advise for a
pattern that is called chaining which is
something that looks like functional
programming for those of you who are a
bit familiar with it the idea is
actually fairly simple you're like okay
those operations they take data frames
as inputs they return data frames so
we're just going to chain them under the
same variable so that we're not going to
actually mutate the initial object into
multiple variants instead we're going to
train those operations I will show you
an example later on of how it looks but
most often people can get stuck in this
mutation pattern
then you also have this attribute in
several
methods in place equals to I assume you
know you all know
um what it is who uses in place equals
true on a frequent basis in their code
don't be shy
so yes it is an interesting attribute
because it allows you indeed instead of
creating a new object to mutate an
existing one that being said if you say
okay I'm going to adopt the chaining uh
the chaining pattern the chaining
pattern assumes that you're going to
return a data frame for the next
operation kind of like when you're
piping things in in Linux here in place
equals true breaks that because it
returns none
this plus the fact that you think that
it's not going to create duplicate items
think again
it won't create a duplicate itself items
when it can but when it cannot it's
actually going to copy at least part of
the data so if the argument
of using in place equal true is to save
memory
it's entirely true
who uses the dot apply function
so
second question which of those two lines
do you think is the most efficient one
the second one right it's also the
simplest one to read actually
and that's again the the problem with
complexity when you realize that you can
apply an arbitrary function to part of
your data frame you're like okay that's
cool and you kind of get stuck into this
sometimes unnecessary complexity
but there is also the fact that
pandas will do what it can to actually
vectorize computation and make it run
more efficiently and Dr play actually
blocks vectorization so when you can if
the function that you're trying to apply
is well simple and can be translated
into simple arithmetics prefer the
simplest option to the second one
because those protocol native operations
will run faster
so this is one thing and please please
please
don't use for Loops it's even better if
you use dot apply I will not mind like
replacing for loops with butterfly but
please please do not use for Loops
because you will entirely forfeit any
possible optimization uh by doing so for
Loops or any uh let's say standard uh
iterative way of manipulating the data
there are some built-in things in pandas
that will take care of things but again
that's the thing when you don't have
like one way of doing things sometimes
it can be confusing and believe me I
have my colleagues who are not from the
data center as well well they're from
you know computer science software
engineering their first idea when they
see the list of series they're like okay
I'm going to it right with the for Loop
no please don't
so
an example of doing things so this uh
these query is actually using a bike
rental data
if we were to like apply the chaining
pattern that I mentioned earlier the
idea would be to do something like this
so actually I have just one object that
you create but then you're going to
change the operations by applying some
filtering processing here for example
than doing a bit of aggregation
and then doing sorting and returning the
object itself
so I am an average pandas user so I
don't claim that this is the most
efficient way of doing things but it was
in a way a good illustration of the uh
of the chaining pattern
what about the other ones modines and
dusk data frame for those it's going to
be quite easy because they actually take
the independence API either as a well a
subset of their API or they try to
replicate it in the case of modin their
goal is in fact to replicate 100 of the
pandas API what they want to do is
actually to build an efficient drop-in
replacement for pandas and ensure full
compatibility
that's one way of looking at things and
that's an interesting one especially
when you want to avoid migrating code to
a new framework
however they're still not there yet it's
quite a lot of work remember there are a
lot of things in pandas itself
and even like some of the the main
methods haven't been let's say ported
yet so if if you were to try the
previous code sample that we showcased
careful because especially the subtle
part is not there yet
and the problem is that when there is
you know this part of the API that you
hit that was imported it's not failing
gracefully instead it is falling back to
pandas which is completely destroying
the performance because you're copying
objects in memory you have to copy a
modding object into a row Panda subject
and then move on with the operation and
this is costing a lot a lot in terms of
performance
third task it's a bit different they
acknowledge that their goal is to use
just a subset of the pandas API they're
not going to replicate it entirely
uh the expertise say in their website
that full coverage is not in their
roadmap that being said they're also
fairly transparent on the fact that some
of the things that were ported are still
expensive in terms of performance
anytime you need to re-index things
anytime you need to sort things you may
encounter let's say performance issues
but at least they are a bit more
transparent about it
and if you were to actually replace
pandas by moding or dusk this code
sample which is the exact same one as in
the previous slide well it actually
works out of the box so that is actually
a good thing if you are to migrate a
huge code base that has pandas at least
taking that small and hopefully
representative sample it kind of works
out out of the box
then comes polars Polaris is a bit
different because they made the choice
to basically discard the pandas API in
favor of something much simpler and more
composable
and they also introduce two types of
apis a lazy one and an eager one I will
get to that later on but they made this
choice to offer let's say a simpler
experience to uh to the user they also
wanted this chaining pattern to be a
first class citizen in how things are
done
uh but the problem is that of course if
you are to migrate from pandas to
Polaris you will need to rewrite your
code
next we're going to talk about memory
that can be a complicated topic
especially when you come from a data
science background so we're not going to
go too deep into the details that being
said it's important to uh to look at
because looking at pandas all in all you
need to think of pandas as basically a
collection of numpy arrays that are
stored in memory an Empire has its own
way of storing things in memory
which has a few implications the first
one being that well uh numpy was built
for numerical computation but what
happens when you have to deal with more
complex different types especially in
the case of strings in the world of
python strings are boxed objects they're
stored as python objects on the hip in
memory and that leads to something that
is called pointer tracing because to
read strings in a sequential way you
will need in a way where to simplify
things to travel a lot in the memory
this leads to potential overhead and not
an efficient way of handling stuff like
string data
same thing when you load data into a
data frame out of the box pandas we'll
do a bit of type inference but if you
really want to limit the amount of
memory that you're going to use and
consume it's always more interesting to
actually manually do the type parsing as
maybe also to change a few types reduce
the number of I don't know bits in which
your integral data is encoded for
example if you want to save memory but
this is still manual work it's not let's
say handled by the pandas inference but
let's type in Friends
modern and dusk again a simple approach
they're basically concatenated data
frames they're reusing the yeah the
pandas memory representation and they
are using those data frames as partition
and meaning that you are going to
partition a mode in data frame or a task
data frame into several smaller pandas
data frames and then dispatch them to
the worker processors or the worker yeah
the worker processes should they be
local or remote so that they can be
processed in parallel
so that's a common pattern for the the
two of them
a quick word regarding partition when it
comes to defining how big should the
partition be and how many of them should
there be
in the case of dusk you have the ability
to fine tune that because given a
certain point in scale you will need to
adjust things to optimize performance
modding took the choice of actually
keeping it transparent and preventing in
a way the user from tweaking this a bit
too much
in the case of polars they're using
something called Arrow so who is or has
heard of the Apache Ro project
all right everyone I don't I will not
have to explain things too much in a way
here we're focusing on something very
specific which is the arrow columnar
format which basically allows you to
represent data in memory in an efficient
way that will allow basically more let's
say a better sequential scans because
you will have data that is let's say you
know a contiguous in memory you will
also have more optimizations around
vectorization and a lot of
interoperability because having one way
to represent the data in memory that has
compatibility with different
tools in the stack or programming
languages will help a lot and will avoid
potentially sub-optimal let's say uh
adaptation code to move from one
framework to the other
something else is that
polars was written in Rust who knows
about the rust programming language
so who writes rest code
so that's for a reason basically rust is
not a language for data science per se
that's a systems programming language
that's very low level but the reason why
rust was chosen was especially to take
care of the potential memory problems
especially when it comes to copying the
data so
Polaris has what is called copy on right
which means that you will be able in
this implementation to actually
efficiently quote unquote copy the data
what does it mean you have a data frame
you want a copy of it but you're just
going to read it you're not going to
alter the data the data frame in rest
you're going to do something that is
called borrowing operation which means
that you're going to create a reference
if you want to write something if you
want a mutable copy of it then you will
have a mechanism allowing you to do so
but in the process it will also check
that it is the only mutable reference
otherwise you will have some a tool that
is called the borrow Checker that is
going to tell you yes but no you're
going to break things if you try to
mutate things like that
so you will have built-in guarantees to
have basically uh
free cloning for read-only and you're
not going to break anything if the
source is in a way altered by one of the
references because there can only be one
mutable reference
last about the execution model
so while pandas is single threaded so I
assume you've all experienced this kind
of feeling when you feel like things are
going really slow on your laptop that
has I don't know a 16 core then you're
like come on uh this is that all you've
got the thing is well there is only one
car working pandas is single threaded
that's the joys of working with python
and the global interpreter lock
uh pandas also only support what is
called the eager execution type meaning
that well when you execute something
when you write code
it will be executed in this exact same
order there will not be any additional
thinking
that's really nice in the case of data
science because you all know that when
you open up a Jupiter notebook it's nice
to have this you know interactive way of
doing things of exploring the data and
whatnot
the thing is in a way first of all it
encourages empty patterns like mutations
and whatnot that we've been talking
about at the beginning
but it will also you know act in a way
that you're going to do first and think
next
at some point you need to flip that
around and say if I need to do a bit of
thinking and if I'm not doing let's say
the the thinking part at least the
engine that is taking care of processing
my query should be able to do so
when you look at something else like
dusk you have something that comes
closer to what you would see in for
example a database when you're building
an execution plan meaning that you're
going to take your query that query will
be translated into something something
that is called a task graph with a few
optimizations on the way and then that
graph will be sent to what we call
schedulers that's also where you need to
make a distinction between
task data frame and the task scheduler
that's the task scheduler is a way to
run workloads in a distributed fashion
either locally or on clusters
that's one way of doing things and in
building this graph you will also get
optimizations on the go
same thing with model and here it's even
more let's say obvious the query is
going to be taken by the query compiler
and then it's going to be translated
into the internal language of modern
which is which they call the data frame
algebra and again on the way this
assumes that we're going to have
optimizations done by the engine so that
at the end of the day when you're going
to push that computation that optimized
computation to the actual let's say
infrastructure part should it be handled
by either array on the bottom right or
by something else like dusk which is
also compatible then at least you will
have something quote unquote simpler
than the initial query that you have
submitted
um in the case of polar same thing the
query will not be executed as is there
will be query optimization as well and
they put an emphasis on the um the
support what they like to call the
support for modern CPU architecture the
sense that anytime you have the ability
to vectorize computation you will be
able to do so because this is built in
in the library to take advantage of the
capacity of modern CPUs to be able to
actually
efficiently run operations that can be
executed in a vectorized way
and on the right you have other examples
of in a way graphs on the top you have
the unoptimized graph and on the bot at
the bottom you have the optimized one
again this is fully handled by the
engine meaning that you only need to say
okay I'll show me the graph for
optimization equals false and then the
one equals true and then of course when
you execute the query it is done with
the optimizations and this really
translates into uh let's say a
noticeable gains in terms of performance
so that was a lot but
in a way it was an interesting take
because
a lot of the content that you have on
the internet in presentation they are
about comparing performance
I wanted to take kind of a different
approach so in a way you can think of
the stalkers kind of a nice prerequisite
to move on to the performance
comparisons next
um well but we're not done yet because
we forgot one thing now it's kind of a
new trend to say okay we have databases
and we don't want to write SQL code we
want to write python code and we want to
write python code in a data frame
friendly way so that well first of all
we had we leverage a language that we
all know and love and second all of the
optimization part all of the scaling
part will be handled by the database
itself so you have several Technologies
and projects that are currently well
available or in the works
um my favorite one is probably the the
Ibis project because the creator of
pandas West McKinney is actually
involved in this one the idea is to
write something that is data frame
related and that you can actually apply
to arbitrary backends should it be
postgres should it be snowflakes should
it be any other database and you don't
want to write SQL that's the same idea
first no part Python and duct TB they
are in an in-memory database that will
allow you to write SQL of course but
also to transfer your code to something
that looks like not really pandas but
something that has a data frame
interface but the engine itself will
still be the database
and well last but not least
um you have realized that we have gone
through a lot of details in this
technical ones it is my belief that at
some point as practitioners of a tool we
have to go beyond just using the tool
and take some time to understand what is
going on under the hood in the
Netherlands I know that people love to
bike but I also know that uh probably
the most experienced bikers well they
wouldn't they will know how to replace
Parts in a bike that we know how a Bike
Works
I I hope my hope is that we achieve that
same status for uh the data science
domain where you have data scientists
not just using tools but also
understanding what it means to compare
that with the theoretical way of how
database work understanding how the
memory is handled understanding API
design and whatnot because all of those
even if it's hidden when you use a tool
it's part of your day-to-day life and
it's uh as a as a cruising way a nice
a nice follow-up if you want to push for
push further your career as a data
scientist and just beyond the day-to-day
data science work understand a bit more
what is running inside your computer or
your cluster
I'm almost finished on time so thanks
for your attention
[Applause]
and if there are questions we still have
nicely within time I think you made all
of us a bit self-conscious about our
pandas code now
uh it's a lot to think about do we have
any questions uh in the audience
there you can have the cube you have to
talk into the little into the thing oh
yes there you go first of all lovely
talk secondly when I was a junior I
remember monitoring my CPU constantly
when I was loading in a large geodata
set because of my blue screen of death
myself
the Juniors that I train nowadays don't
even know where the blue screen is
because CPU capacity and cloud computing
went so fast so my question is are we
getting lazy
um so probably so it's interesting
because so uh I work as a developer
advocate in my company but I'm also in
charge of Technical enablement and when
I have to explain what is under the hood
sometimes people are like but I never
saw that in school and like well maybe
it's uh it's a good first step I'd say
but it's also the goal of the ecosystem
you know to abstract with the complexity
it's just that at some point there is a
threshold in which you need to actually
gear up and say okay I want to be more
efficient then I'm going to open the
hood and see what is going on
thank you
were there any questions I think I saw
cements here oh all the way in the back
you think you can reach all the way in
the back
can you fold up your hand and be ready
to catch
oh
was it was it it was it was a decent
throw
can you hear me
you got it yes there we go
good catch
[Applause]
thank you first of all for this nice
overview of all these packages that we
have I I started as a like working with
python is like about six months but I'm
wondering like for your type of works
that you do what kind of combination of
this uh packages you use to scale up a
little bit uh
uh yeah the performance
so uh at that I could actually use
pandas uh we use pandas as basically a
universal interface because at the graph
that I show in the beginning the idea is
to give users access to the data in the
form of a data frame not in the form of
a CSV file or a SQL table and whatnot we
build actually an abstraction layer on
top of that so that like regardless of
the data source people only manipulate
data frames
and even though I have my complaints
against pandas the thing is it's an
industry standard and that is actually
something that you can't really fight
meaning that if pandas is used
everywhere then it becomes kind of a
standard uh all of the packages that
I've shown so modern desk polars and
whatnot
pushing that to production
will be kind of not really a long shot
but people will be a bit more
uh afraid of doing that versus trusting
pandas which is uh fairly old and battle
tested so there is the performance
question of course but there is also the
usability and the reusability if you
have a pull-up user that is already
familiar with pandas and that need to
move forward especially when it has
links to production related projects
then yes by all means you can stick to
pandas otherwise my favorite one would
be polar
um but the other two so modin does can
even the other one like red frames fakes
and whatnot they all have their
advantages it will really depend on the
use case the size of the data and the
level of experience and familiarity of
the data scientists we're going to use
them
I think we still have time for another
question if there's
uh oh there's a okay up there first
I'm a huge fan of polars I think it's
awesome when I discovered it was like oh
my God how did I miss that so thank you
for bringing that to everyone's
attention as well but I struggle a
little bit of trying to convince others
to go from panelists to polos right so I
play around with it I see it's fast I I
looked under the hood I'm a big fan but
it's not the standard so how do you kind
of convince people to say it's okay to
embrace change how do you tell people
it's a deep question and I have 27
seconds
[Laughter]
um
well
um again it depends for me pandas is
there to stay that being said it's not
an excuse not to innovate if you want to
take a look at something like polars
today it's not really to push code in
production with it tomorrow it's more to
understand what can be the benefits in
the long run and once you have that then
you can go to your boss and the boss can
go to their bus and say okay now we have
a case for it let's experiment let's do
a POC let's replace parts of the stack
and then go progressively replacing
pandas in one day that's complex
that's why you have so many libraries
that actually aim for full competivity
in terms of the API that's already
reassuring
but otherwise it's yeah it's betting
it's innovating that's something you
need to keep doing as a company as a
startup as an Enterprise company you
have to keep to keep it doing but you
also have to keep the lights on and for
that you need your production projects
to to run so yeah find the balance
between both
it's hard to Dethrone the King right yes
then that's it for time uh all your
remaining questions uh you're still
around for today right yep so you can
ask your questions actually now because
we have a short Coffee Break
um next Talk starts at 10 55 so if you
want to be here for be here at 10 55 or
in any of the other rooms on time
um thank you again thank you
[Applause]